so computer scientists and developers
right they wants to be able to take
these 256 characters 256 characters and
they wanted to represent these in a more
concise way right so think about this
with me think if I have base 10 base 10
then if I have say okay two characters
right
each one has ten possibilities so I have
a hundred different options does that
make sense a hundred different
characters I can represent here five 256
256 a square number right what's it
equal to it'll be 16 so if I had a base
not base 10 or base 2 if I had a base 16
system I could represent all 256 of
these characters with two letters two
characters each of which have 16
different possibilities 16 base 10 is
called decimal
there's twos called binary base 16 this
book does anyone know what it's called
well you want you want 10 and then you
want to add 6 right so they call it
hexadecimal okay now again this just has
been borne out of computers okay so
here's the way it counts here's the make
count I'm going to count and hexadecimal
for you okay you ready here we go 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 9 so far so good right 10 11
12 13 14 15
okay so in total if I add my zero there
you see this is base 16 my biggest
single character is 1 less than that
just like in base 10
your biggest single character is 1 less
than 10 and in base 2 your biggest
single character it's one less than 2
it's just 1 so therefore how do you read
stuff like this let's um I'm gonna pull
out 25 again right won't for the first
time 25 how would I write 25 decimal in
something hexadecimal how am I going to
do it think about how he translated
before what would you let me to draw up
hmm I think I can draw up a table of
just 2 days you can do it
this first one will be units right units
but a better more info informative way
of saying it is its how many 16 to the
power of zeros I have 16 - Caillou my
second digit will be how many 16 how
many 6 needs to have one okay how these
six things are there in 25 there is one
okay how many ones are left behind there
are nine right hmm that's a bit weird
right this is 25 in decimal if I write
it in hexadecimal okay let's think that
some other numbers let's use the UM
let's use the fancy extra new characters
that we've got which are just all
characters that we've just repurposed
isn't that funny how things go in cycles
remember we said Bank or people who were
here on Wednesday we said on Roman
numerals revenues are funny because they
just used regular letters to represent
numbers like you you only know that
these are numbers because you see them
in a particular context right well we've
kind of gone all the way back to doing
that we've again we're using letters to
represent numbers okay try this on for
size
what's this number this is hexadecimal
right how do I convert this
into decimal what do we check the
decimals sorry each of the digits what
do they stand for what's this number
this is in decimal it's 10 right and
that's how many 16s you have so that
means it's a number so I can a the
number 10 lots of 16 160 right and then
what's this this is this is 14 - how
many units I have so it would be a new
60 plus 14
so be a hundred and fifty four so the
decimal self I can't say yeah 74 sorry
okay what's the biggest number I can
represent in just two characters it'll
be an F right F if that's the biggest
digits I have and like we established
before it's gonna be this node right 255
in decimal which is 1 1 1 1 1 point 1 1
in binary okay so you can see how these
larger bases right
they make numbers more concise but you
have to know more characters to be able
to read it what would this number be
what would that be that's hexadecimal
this is gonna be a big number right how
would you work it out what does that
mean it's 15 lots of what 16 squared 16
to the power 2 all right plus one lot of
16 to the power 1 plus C lots let's see
let's see 10 11 12 plus 12 I don't know
what this is can someone get reach a
calculator and tell me what it is anyone
anyone there
please tell me doesn't exploit your
calculator these numbers on that Big
Mike can you read it for me G cool hey
do you see these three digits become
these balls sorry should write down the
base yeah okay become these four digits
in decimal and you can actually it's not
that hard to write for yourself even in
something like Excel them writer
translator between these two or even go
to binary I'm not even gonna Baba try
try to write this in binary quick
question for you I would make answer now
but how would you work out how many
digits you would need to represent that
in binary don't answer it just think
about it can it be sold without doing it
just you know by trial and error can you
take an analytical approach to it